le golf veut continuer sa transition
écologique ce mardi 12 avril la
fédération française a signé un
partenariat avec l'agencé de l'eau seine
normandie au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines objectif mieux gérer
la gestion de l'eau sur et autour des
greens les travaux notamment nécessaire
dans certains golfs construit dans les
années 80 les systèmes aujourd'hui sont
bien évidemment plus performants qui à
30 ans mais en prenant les bonnes
décisions qui n'étaient pas forcément
qu'ils étaient les bonnes décisions 10 à
30 ans il ya trente ans on pouvait
arrosé l'erreur on pouvait arroser des
zones qui n'étaient pas des zones
indispensables aujourd'hui si on veut
préserver les ressources en eau il faut
faire des choix et quand vous arrivez à
cumuler ces deux intérêts qui sont de 1
mieux arroser certains espaces que vous
choisissez avec un matériel plus
performant et bien on arrive tout de
suite à des économies en termes d'eau
d'utilisation d'eau et c'est ce qu'on
recherche à travers cette convention
entre autres cette convention prévoit
des objectifs chiffrés sur les trois
prochaines années et des axes de travail
dans 163 golf présents sur le bassin
seine et normandie donc l'objectif c'est
de réduire de 30 % la quantité de
produit samedi une phytosanitaires
utilisés sur les golfs du bassin il ya
des objectifs en termes d'économies de
aussi 250 mille mètres cubes d'eau
seront économisés sur les trois ans de
la convention grâce à des
investissements qui permettent bas une
irrigation plus contrôlés plus maîtrisée
nous avons aussi des objectifs en termes
de désintermédiation ce qu'on appelle la
d imperméabilisation de permettre à
l'eau de s'infiltrer jusqu'en 2024
lagence peut aider les golfs dans leur
transition écologique en apportant entre
40 et 60% dead pour investir dans le
matériel la structure peut également
financer des études préalables aux
investissements entre 50 et 70%